born in Tamil name of my lava
liwa Poland I would say I had a very
happy childhood thinking back and to my
comes it's growing up brother one
brother and one sister I would say a
lower little class family terms of
financial status as I can think back but
nothing was lacking in the house in
terms of provide having what we needed
and want it remember the beautiful play
mates and their friends and school
classmates and school friends childhood
normal uneventful but rather surrounded
by warm family there was an isolation
between Jews and Christians in my
hometown you know when I try to compare
it to what we have here Jewish boys and
girls mixing in open society with
non-jewish kids that was not my
experience growing up we went to Jewish
schools we had Jewish areas we had our
Jewish synagogues and and frequently or
occasionally is being beaten up by a
bunch of Christian called
Christian kids who called me a Christ
killer or something that nature that was
so we there was we grew up in a kind of
an isolation as far as the Jewish
community is concerned Pisa was it was a
very joyous occasion my father sitting
at the seder really like a king which is
supposed to have a connotation of
freedom
and this is the implication when the
father leans on the pillows and the
preparation and mother and my
grandmother's was to quit would come to
the Seder both grandmother's seems not
seems I know that they are my
grandfather's died young both on both
sides before I was born so the
grandmothers came to our home for us for
the Seder and there were some cousins
and uncles and aunts the preparation the
joy the beauty of the table it was an
experience of a religious spiritual
nature that nothing can compare of
course on the other hand you have the
solemn days you know Rosh Hashanah Yom
Kippur but really this is the holiday
that the children look forward to I
remember going to my grandmother's
before the holiday in our days when you
want matzo meal you go into the store
you bake it over there my grandmother
would give me not see if I would only
produced from the matzo matzo meal so
that she can make Nayla and for the year
for the goodies father for the Passover
meals but the Seder and the entire
holiday was one choice expert didn't go
to school and we were free all we have
to do is go to the synagogue and eat and
be with the family and go visitations it
is something that it cannot be
duplicated as much as we try course and
we do have up to this day Passover the
special special season for us in our own
home but I suppose what's lacking is the
extended family in my case that's not
there and talking about extended family
I recover my son of us to be Bar Mitzvah
and he was permit so there was no one on
my side
that's why my wife has a brother who's a
rabbi to the time his grandfather my
mother were alive you know for my
mother's my wife's sight but there was
no more for my family joy talking about
that I never discussed it with my son he
never did he discuss with me which
thinking back now I suppose I wanted to
protects plane why I didn't but all
kinds of did I want to protect myself
and not to be living it I doubted I
don't know I don't think this is the
reason but the fact is that moments of
the sword is a Passover or it's a Bar
Mitzvah or a wedding you're alone but
quite be hope but loneliness has various
various aspects to it
I remember after liberation
I suffered probably more from the
loneliness in the isolation more than
during all the coast period and I
thought about it the other day and I
suppose it has to do with the fact that
after life around you seems to be normal
but you are abnormal well why in the
concentration camps and labor camps
there was a the occupation with survival
preoccupation with being thrown around
and how can I make the next day but then
after it was called liberation actually
the realization of liberation was not
vivid he was not real with me for a long
time
but I remember 20 years 45 46 47 even
after 48 I would find myself crying and
quite frequently there feeling there's
no one there's no one around me that
cares what I do or what I don't do and
many other aspects to it that I suppose
has to do with loneliness feeling of yes
I'm alive but that's the that's it the
rest doesn't matter you're in the midst
of a fire burning and still there was
kind of a denial I have a lower come do
you yeah yeah I remember thinking that
it's not as bad somehow God will help
not recognizing that God helps those who
help themselves
looking at it from a historical
perspective although on the other hand
one may ask did it really have much of a
choice which is another area it's it's
it's a bit complex as I see it it's not
as yes historically one can say usual
came into being because finally Jews got
together and decided they want to do
something about it instead of waiting
for God to create it for them question
is whether that chance would they have
had if they had done it let's say 200
years before that would they still
succeed in creating what they did was a
request also of the the political the
timing was more right for one action
than another
nobody will never net will ever know but
the fact is that in my circles a
dependency on faith I mean a lot of
faith Allah God will help I was a part
of the psychic of the psyche of the we I
was earlier with that I identified with
oh we don't Pat times we had bad times
there may be bad times that
bad times I'm out cattle help German
army were their troops and their power
was self-evidence right away with your
always mechanized it wasn't for this the
Polish army was mostly but rather ground
well the force was evident to our
pleasant surprise at the moment was at
the first contact with German soldiers
was rather a pleasant one they did not
bother us as Jews on the contrary they
would come into the house they would ask
for drinks and would offer them drinks
it would and all the fear that we had
accumulated for the Germans to come in
in the first few days with incense any
and I think I think this was by design
I I would say that the troops were not
to be involved in any of the Gestapo in
any of the SS objectives and aim they
had to do their job to be friendly to
the year to leave a sense of security at
least this is the way I interpreted that
the people should not to be frightened
it was only a few days after when they
settled in hometown they arrested the
rabbi of the community meaning German
stop of the year he was arrested with
the number of prominent citizens and not
knowing what's going to happen and they
announced that if any to does anything
wrong these are going to be shot to
death so here is a frightening thing
that after a few days they let them go
they're making them responsible for a
number of laws which they instituted
immediately after that not all at once
the one that every Jew must register
every Jew must have a number later on a
Jew must carry a must must have a white
first was a white round sign that he's a
Jew and front in the back
marijuana's was changed to a yellow
later one that an announcement was made
at Jew must walk if he sees a German
must Wow must go off the sidewalk he
must go below the street and you must
take off his hat when he sees a German
German has the right to call on any Jew
any time for work any kind of work he
wants to and then supposedly truly
representatives which ultimately became
the you drat they he should lost that
every Jew at 200 you every day every 200
Jews must appear in the marketplace for
Germans to come in the morning to to
pick out people to work ok so then this
developed into a numbers first it was by
numbers number stone so must appear that
almost immediately became became a
source of ink or something as strange as
it may seem if someone didn't want to
appear he would ask me if I wanted to go
for him he would pay me for day's work
in my case my father managed to save
some of his merchandise and he was able
to have to carry on throughout that
period although he was caught one day
and disappeared with all of us going
crazy I remember my mother
practically I risked her life pleading
with the German authorities there in
City Hall to try to send him back to
find out where he is no veo
to no avail except after a month he came
back my father was never to say where
had this Santa I never talked about it
obviously it was a labor camp of some
sort you needed him for harvesting the
potatoes or whatever it was so he worked
very hard there they cut his beard and
he he became a different different
person well I know him to be the dynamic
all-knowing strong he became very much
reserved since then although he took
well care of his family over the five of
us Mike went to grandmother's moved in
with us and one cousin of ours oh we
were eight and we stayed in the
apartment he managed to do business
secretly with against the law with
people who came in to buy things and
they would knew him customers who knew
him before so he was able to sell some
of the merchandise and provide for for
his family food at that time you know it
was bad whenever we look back it was
great that's good it was good
the family was together and there was a
feeling you also war the war will be
over and there was no inclination no
idea of no question about survival I
mean it's a question of hard times this
is the Sabbath day that's the first time
I had to work in the Sabbath and since
of course they gave us some food but
since it wasn't kosher I would need
because I got smarter later
unfortunately
but to me it was a trauma of the worst
kind being rather sheltered young man
that was very traumatic but thinking
back or what happened afterwards I think
some that's so bad it's okay so I was
beaten up so what talking about beating
up I will never forget the first time I
was beaten up and that really got to me
not so much the not so much D the pain
from the beating but the mental anguish
instead of telling me how to put bricks
together I had to be placed in certain
way in order for them to be stucked up
and each simply went over and beat me
for it not knowing why and I couldn't
even cry when I came home this is when I
burst out crying animal they asked old
used to appear in the marketplace there
and I've already trucks there too to be
putting us on and all of a sudden that
stopped they sent us back home what
happened I don't know some thought that
there was a German High officer passed
by and he told him to stop it there was
a lot of crying I remember and this is
incidentally the first time I saw my
father cry they were they were all of us
standing together braced and I just
burst out crying he just lost lost sense
of of you know being being a father
being caring for a family but he has no
power to protect his family
I remember I was still studying with the
rabbi out of town you know privately
would meet daily secretly we would study
and that night before one of the leaders
of the universe came to tell the rabbi
there that he just spoke with the
authority there that
so tell everybody everything's gonna be
fine and the following morning my
mother's in the freighting can my mother
used to get up very early on Fridays
preparing for the Sabbath she would go
to the bakery in the morning you start
paring and she came back and she said to
walk everybody up that's it but there
are Germans all over town and it's
impossible to to go out without being
stopped she backed off and came back we
lived a bit outside of the town and he
was standing all depressed there were
two grandmother's with us my cousins
were eight of us each one were they
ready to go and we were hoping maybe
they will not see us we didn't know
what's happening outside so then we saw
a Polish kid was telling the Germans
here are Jews so they came up with dogs
and whips really suddenly happened again
which is buried but you know when you
talked that particular morning comes to
mind so vividly my father was holding on
to his mother she couldn't run as fast
as the rest of us and I looked back and
I was in the street a snowing and here
he was holding on to his mother and dogs
attacked him there was a German whipping
him his mother the floor ground and him
not wanting to go eventually we were
running and we were taken to a place oh
yeah was the I was like here high school
sports place
and there were thousands of us there and
we finally looked for each other we
found my father there crying missing his
mother the rest of us were waiting and
after some time they wheeled to my
grandmother - the group - and wagon but
that group consisted about seven
thousands all the Jews from the town
well we can say we're all what most of
us were there in that place obviously
they decided to create a getter there
and they decided the cattle should be
only about 3,000 3,500 Jews remaining in
the rest of us but evacuated so my
family together was evacuated to a
person were taken to to a small village
not far from my hometown we stayed there
about ten eleven days it's a terrible
humiliation I mean those things are
forgotten we were in barracks tears
sleeping and buncha straw feeding was
once a day the humiliation of the worst
kind I mean I was I just couldn't
couldn't deal I remember I just couldn't
deal with the whole thing but eleven
days we were there and after that we
were put on trains in three groups there
are about 3,000 of us about thousands in
three different communities into Poland
proper which is now the post
Protectorate my group came to a town but
in a blue bottle near Lublin
because after a two days travel I guess
we arrived here and Wednesday I
remembered the Jewish community there
dealt with now a thousand refugees
marvelously they assigned us different
homes three children one place with a
dentist I remember my cousin in the
different place my father and his mother
in one place my mother and her mother a
different place the following day we got
together and my grandmother died at
night sitting on her mother on my
mother's lap you know there was no room
there to put her so she didn't feel good
so she's on the chair of this type set
together and hugging each other and she
just expired but she was buried that
same day and looking back I suppose she
had she merited to be buried like a like
a human being
and two days later my other grandmother
died of fright that time there were two
other friends of mine particular and we
were caught traveled by train of course
they knew I'm sure that we are coming
back against the law and they put us in
a labor camp where in this is my
hometown some relatives of mine maid had
been in the gettin out by that time
there was a gator there when they heard
that I was in the prison in this city
town prison labor camp which was turned
into a labor camp I remember they tried
to make contact they succeeded making
contact I remember that it was a Friday
when I saw them at the gates you know
they were probably human permission to
see me
it was it was a very emotional meeting
they brought in some food this was
Friday the Friday meant very special to
me they brought me a challah all the
emotions you know what happened to the
whole thing you know this is my hometown
or this was a special day especially
evening special food with here I am
may 28th us at the end of May I was
liberated from that labor camp back into
the ghetto yeah I then I felt was in
skirt I mean people know me and people
my family they worked for me they got
them clothes for me already oh I was
wearing the same clothes for three
months ago I remember the buttons of my
coat had been ripped off when I was
going around her there was a piece of
rope holding my come together they gave
me new clothes and I started were to get
work and I worked and I saved some money
I remember what I ate or didn't get all
together I wanted to save money to get
my family back in here and that summer I
succeeded to get my mother and brother I
don't remember how I got money to them
how I smuggle get people there were it
was some smuggling going on there and
they got my money and some letters and
my mother and brother younger brother
managed to come to the ghetto
of course the cat in my sister as I
mentioned before had decided no she must
stay with her father how they survived I
don't know you mentioned Passover before
I remember meeting my mother she told us
about the seder between that was
Passover
I remember that pastor with you I wasn't
that other labor camp
but my mother described to me the
Passover without me
my father just I didn't know where he
was
there was no way of communicating with
him that I'm alive that I wear and my
father was simply carrying on that Seder
morning after son so this is where my
mother were somewhere mother last times
November 9th on a Tuesday I guess she
was had she was worried she was
it was angry right
it was it I guess that camp I tried to
find out where that transport went
possibly Treblinka
there was one forgot you know the
distraction of for European Jewry
hilberg hilberg ie check with the hombre
he he claims the death transport he did
a lot of study in that subject it went
to Auschwitz I don't know how you some
reason that didn't think so because no
one of that transport survived just know
one week later my brother na has to
appear well then the tow Tuesday all saw
the week after we spend the night here
in a mill in the following day we were
put on trains and then end up in
Auschwitz the race tonight November 20th
I believe it was 19 or 20th my brother
and I were together and he was separated
from me not knowing where we are what
this is of course later one I learned it
he was went to the crematorium
as far as my father and sister is
concerned that same month iris we
received a card from her saying in a
postcard you need kind of a secret
language the gist of it was that we
don't know what's going to happen what
we was able to gather is that the same
amount of the liquidation of many other
places throughout Poland as November 42
I was lucky of the transport of 2500
went to Auschwitz one of the 500 it
seems about hundred and fifty so young
people my age group were taken into a
Maurer Shula there was a school for
masons of how to become pre-cleared what
that intention was I know simply
speaking I suppose they wanted to get
the benefit of young people who can
still build and and serve their purpose
for me it was lucky because although at
times I didn't think I was lucky but I
wish that would be the other side but
the fact that I was spent that winter
within the confines of the buildings
without going out to work at least
that's the way I see it he gave me a
chance to adjust to a different to the
environment and the whole bit of
concentration cape life and the fact is
that this number sixty seven thousand
seventy six thousand three hundred
seventy six thousand was a group of
people of my hometown and were taken to
that camp probably we never made this
proportionally probably more of them so
what more of us survives in that group
than from in any other group and there
was a group of us seventy six thousand
that
we could still know of each other we
spent this summer the winter there by
the spring we were pushed out the
workforce and that was life and
Conservation Camp to continue until
January 18 1945 even even later on up
1945 when I was taking to book a while
later on in Inge after January 1945 I
remember or praying going to and from
work what comes to mind is one day a one
of the inmates in Auschwitz noticed that
I am praying and he came up with him as
an elderly gentleman identified himself
and he told me he comes from a series of
concentration camp before Auschwitz he
was a German Jew he was arrested too
near 1930s her being accused of being a
communist then he was imprisoned but by
the time he was to be free from prison
the law was that any Jew who is is not
to go out from prison but the brother be
sent in concentration camp and he told
me that he was actually an atheist but
in prison being there isolated alone he
gave a lot of thought and he became
attracted to religion so he asked me if
I could say some prayers with him we did
he in turn had another friend a young
friend also from Germany and the three
of us formed a kind of a year of a
friendship but never would we work
together we would stand to mix the
cement or carry the cement or carry the
calls and he would say with me some of
the prayers I would share some thoughts
that I remembered by heart you know of
classic statements in there so it seems
that I was I was nun questioning at
least not heavily to the point of I was
was legitimate to do
you know from what I understand it now
but I suppose the the the idea of fate
was so much ingredient meat it was a
kind of a second nature of mine that was
even when I was in carving coal which
was a terrible terrible experience
towards the end much worse than outfits
I still remember at that time I guess it
was a getting to a point of resignation
but what happened afterwards but I still
find myself reciting the minify service
you know going to work
but this was that kept me going possibly
I don't know you know some who didn't
have that kind of faith and is still
survived many who had more faith than I
did I'm sure did not survive there's no
rhyme or reason no explanation of why
once a wire to the other did not
two days later we were sent to a order
of camp which is in outskirts of maha
while tourists from order we went to
carving coal every by the end of January
I was in carving coal which was a
horrifying experience it wasn't the
tearing in mountains we had to drill for
bunker stairs very hard work food was
much less than in Auschwitz the living
conditions much less is how shoots one
it was very clean the one wanted to keep
himself clean was ideal I would go up
and we look for foot for a fire quickly
morning I would wash myself and called
Warren's was really for me it was a good
thing you know
it was sanitary near but not carving go
was filthy and was food was and I felt
that I'm getting weaker by the day
they're going to and from work was a
long distance by walking
however being painful my join started to
ache but he beginning of April that camp
was obviously becoming closer to the
Americans coming from the West we were
sent back to Baja wild that too took a
few days of marching and bombing I
believe it's getting ourselves into the
forest I remember coming to Buchenwald
talk was that this camp is going to be
blown up is it good to go out with a
transporter to remain although it wasn't
our decision to commit anyway but we
never knew what's good and it turns out
I was taken out April 10th
from bald and April 11 that camp was
liberated
I checked with he likewise l who was
liberated that care and yes it was some
April eleventh he was liberated and
between April 10th and my liberation I
went to which was within three four
weeks I probably suffered more than in
the years before physically I remember
being in trains and cattle trains with
losing my strength remember my breathing
was becoming very heavy I can see myself
picking my saw as having my as I've seen
others in the last days of their lives
reaching a point where I didn't even
want to go down from the train because
he had to jump down from a cattle train
which is high in order to get some food
or whatever I just didn't want to go
down that touches too much of an effort
I just wanted to be left alone my dear
it is this what I have a block a black
out of my memory I remember vaguely
coming to a place where I was
disinfected and again a black cow
completely that must have been to raise
dad because when I came to I found
myself in the in hospital hospital into
raisin under the Russians I would cry
out cry a lot just anything if you would
talk to me just talk to me I will start
crying
why because and I said to myself is it
true that you're talking to me why
should you talk to me it's probably not
true I was a halt confusion on the whole
thing of existence obviously pleased to
my way of thinking that they got us to
at least they got me to think of myself
so little that nobody should talk about
to me what this does it takes years and
again here if I may interject that
religious thought is the idea that it's
imperial potential in the human being it
can purr to himself
even with his own bootstraps of course I
met my wife was just marvelous I'll be
remarried rather soon right after when I
look back is it how dare die
how dare ya know whether here the United
States
how dare die and I was married almost as
soon as I came here came in 1940 I was
married in 1948 no one would otherwise
well this as long as I suppose possibly
for me it worked my son was born in 1950
but I can tell you I was not well
mentally but mentally I mean I wasn't
crazy I wasn't doing I wasn't doing
anything outlandish at least I don't
think so
but but my insight my insight was
definitely scarred I can tell you of
course there have been some not issues
but rather difficulties between my son
and myself not in a sense of becoming
hostile to each other but not the
current relationship you would that I
would want to see and I noticed it
during his high school years his a
brilliant young man is an attorney now
he it was a good excellent student who
went Brandeis graduated magna [ __ ] laude
if I may be proud of but looking back I
missed and I miss it terribly now the
fact that I was too busy and he wanted
more of me I wasn't there
now which is it is it fair to come close
to you
is it wanting to be normal so much so
that I immersed myself in my work all
kinds of hours or what but I suppose
these as sort of scars that I mentioned
before that are with us I suppose will
be buried with them trying I hope that I
can make a change in my if I may share
personal feelings I've been the next
lasts a couple years maybe I should
change my position so that I can spend
more time with my son W Jesus left
simply try to make up lost years